archeologists have just uncovered
evidence of a Native American
civilization that vanished completely
vanished in the 13th century and that
amazing yeah partly they died out months
after selecting their new leader chief
trump they found a skull with a big
orange wig on him scowling at them but
it was the best go you've ever seen god
these are crazy times thanks for being
here yesterday this is interesting a
Russian spy plane was spotted over New
Jersey yeah yeah the Russian pilot was
overheard saying you know Siberia is not
so bad
can I just compliment this crowd if
they're at when I give the set up they
go Oh better than just about any crowd
I've ever heard no now you're applauding
yourselves and that's that's really sad
some football stadiums are going to
begin offering delivery services that
bring food right to your seat yeah
settle down no it is true give me the
set up again there Bongo I forget where
I am no football stadiums are going to
be this get a delivery system yeah that
will bring food right to your seat
that's amazing yeah however if you're a
Rams fan your food will most likely be
intercepted and returned for a touchdown
[Applause]
they're fine too laughs in New Jersey
minute it gets close to home you like
you know don't mess with my nachos yeah
I don't think that's the part they
object oh that's all I heard oh you just
heard not show yeah yeah hey Walmart is
testing out an app that would allow
shoppers to skip the checkout line yeah
yeah currently that service is known as
shoplifting I got a million jokes here
I don't know what that was hey the
singer of the weekend is reportedly can
see ah the weekend is reportedly
considering changing his name yeah yeah
this is on the advice of his son
staycation I'm sorry we had we had a
debate backstage about that I didn't
really not sure how that went weird
story in Virginia someone broke into a
man's apartment cleaned it and took
nothing completely clean the place yeah
police are describing the suspect as his
mother
left out she's armed and neurotic
Chipotle has closed a location in Dallas
you probably maybe saw this video after
diners filmed three rats falling from
the ceiling yes don't worry the rats
died of e.coli before they hit the
ground
a recent study just came out found that
sex burns about 3.5 calories per minute
[Applause]
it's funny cuz that was always my pickup
line hey baby want to come back to my
place and burn seven calories
you
you